florian syli pour le vice président du
front national est la tête de liste pour
ce parti à l'élection européenne du 25
mai dans l'est de la france est
l'invitée de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse à dailymotion avec
ce soir guillaume daudin et bien sûr
perrine tarneaud est ce que votre liste
est prête
monsieur philippe raoux il ya des
prêtres jusqu'au prête moi je repars de
la liste des joueurs français pour le
mondial de frites etc là y'a pas utile
60 millions de sélectionneurs peut-être
vous aussi parce que vous aimeriez alors
je suis jamais fait partie de ces 60
millions c'est 60 millions - ans ça doit
être moi alors est-ce qu'il faut
néanmoins jugé selon le temps pas très
bon c'est vrai mais si je me demande par
exemple est-ce qu'il faut exiger un test
de marseillaise aux joueurs français
non mais je le préfère quand il chanta
marseillaise françois loridan comme tous
les français je crois françois hollande
ce mardi a refusé en arménie de
commenter at il dit les polémiques
ridicules au sujet du reproche qui était
fait à christiane taubira de ne pas
avoir donc entonné la marseillaise
alors qu'une solis l'interpréter mais je
ne comprends pas très bien le fait de
justement de ne pas commenter cette
affaire parce que ce n'est pas
totalement anodin contrairement à ce
qu'il dit je crois que ça a choqué
beaucoup beaucoup de français le fait
donc elle ne chante pas la marseillaise
ostensiblement qu'elle refuse de la
chanter ça vole acceptez vous acceptez
la jeunesse est pas très bien plus
nanoro qu'elle renonce voyais on parlait
tout le recueillement plutôt que
l'interprétation se voit même avec
l'envolée vu son explication totalement
alambiqué le recueillement trois petits
points plutôt que le karaoké d'estrade
donc elle considère que les autres
ministres et je le faisais du karaoké
quoi je dire si ces voix là d'abord on
comprend pas très bien ce silence et
surtout ensuite ses explications
explications de mme taubira sont pour le
moins surprenantes voire inconvenante je
veux dire dans n'importe quel autre pays
un ministre de la république un ministre
qui parlerait ainsi deux lignes de
national serait débarqué dans l'eure
dans l'eure ils démissionneraient par
des sens où il serait débarqué elle ne
veut pas démissionner mais normalement
françois hollande devrait prendre ses
responsabilités j'adhère derrière la
marseillaise c'est évidemment un symbole
de la france de la nation de la
république mais c'est aussi un champ sur
lequel
beaucoup de résistants sont morts ont
été fusillés ils ont entonné pendant
qu'ils étaient en train d'être tués
je veux dire c c'est un chant qui
résonne au delà même des frontières de
la france qui résonne alors pour
l'ensemble des patriotes du monde qui
sont attachés aux valeurs de liberté
s'est tenue cette polémique est née le
10 mai dernier un puisque c'est la date
anniversaire du vote de la loi taubira
justement sur l'abolition de l'esclavagé
il n'y a pas eu de commémoration cette
année dans la ville que vous détenez
dans l'aisne s'il y en a une
enfin n'a pas officiel pas par votre
mère arrive à lire les deux ça comment
est-ce que vous jugez cette attitude si
vous voulez le moment non mais moi moi
je serai un peu l'analyse de marine le
pen c'est à dire que moi je pense que
non mais c'est vrai je pense qu'il peut
être qu'il aurait dû y aller c'est aimer
le dire parce que non mais ce n'était
pas stupide mais je comprenais j'ai
compris ce qu'il voulait dire niant
maréchal et c'est son expression mais
j'ai compris non c'est pas mon
expression
j'ai compris ce qu'il voulait dire il en
a un peu plein le dos de soul et de la
repentance permanent de la
culpabilisation de la france et des
français c'est vrai qu'on en a marre
fuir tous les trois mois
on nous explique que la france a très
mal s'est très mal comporté dans le
passé sur tel ou tel mais l'art sur le
bout d'un moment tu as tort aux
fondations on a aussi une histoire
glorieuse qu'il faudrait mettre en avant
bon ensuite je pense surtout quand on
lutte contre l'esclavagé parce que c'est
quand même le signal qu'on veut envoyer
légitime
il faut parler de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et l'esclavagé aujourd'hui
malheureusement ça existe toujours dans
le monde
ça existe par exemple qatar voyais on
parlait du foot il y aurait une coupe du
monde je crois de football en 2022 au
qatar est un chantier est les chantiers
un peu partout là bas en cours et des
immigrés indiens par exemple à 400
immigrés indiens qui sont déjà morts sur
le chante sur les chantiers du qatar
voilà ça ce sont des esclaves modernes
et voilà moi je serais allé à 7 5 me et
puis j'aurai j'aurais parlé d' esclavage
moderne d'accord et à vous y seriez en
tous les cas aller
en ce qui vous concerne cinq jeunes
français parti pour le djihad en syrie
il ya quelques semaines jusqu'à un terme
que vous avez employé le mot de
polémique sur man taubira oui j'aurais
les mika tout et ancien chef de gestion
des tma tierce et remet d'un multi
polémique ridicule a dit le chevreuil
est assez ridicule de sa part de pas y
répondre surtout c'est mais c'est à une
polémique
tout n'est pas polémique il ya des
sujets qui font partie du débat
politique madame taubira les ministres
elle est responsable de ses actes de ses
écrits de ses paroles elle doit s'en
justifier son expliqué je ne sais il n'y
a pas de polémique là dedans il ya
simplement un débat
cinq jeunes français qui étaient partis
faire le djihad en syrie et quelques
montées étaient interpellées à
strasbourg ce mardi matin qu'est ce
qu'on fait de ces jeunes endoctrinés
déjà le phénomène est manifestement
encore plus important qu'on ne
l'imaginait cela nous donne ça donne
raison à aux analyses que nous faisons
sur l'ampleur du phénomène qui concerne
des centaines de jeunes français qui
vont parfaire et l'emploi djihad en
syrie de l'ampleur du réaction la
réaction du ministre de l'intérieur
également
c'est assez faiblard déjà il a fallu le
temps pour qu'il prenne conscience de
l'existence du phénomène pour qu'ils
l'acceptent et ensuite pour réagir nous
sommes aussi à quelques jours des
élections européennes aux conseils qu'on
va probablement multiplié les actions
médiatiques et les français ne sont plus
tout à fait dupe de cela parce qu'il ya
pas de politique cohérente il faudrait
normalement renforcer les moyens du
renseignement français de renseignement
barça a commencé avec la révision grâce
à eux qu'ils ont été remerciés mais je
m'en remets pas en cause le travail des
fonctionnaires du renseignement qui est
tout à fait remarquable mais depuis
nicolas sarkozy avec la réf la révision
générale des politiques publiques la
rgpp que les fonctionnaires connaissent
bien on a un fond dre les moyens de
l'état dans un certain nombre de
domaines notamment le renseignement bon
ma effondrés les budgets et les moyens
humains et matériels bon là c'est un
vrai un vrai problème parce qu'on a
besoin du renseignement ensuite il faut
le il faut lutter beaucoup plus
fermement contre ce phénomène la
surveiller les prêches faire en sorte
que quand on sait qu'un jeune est parti
là bas faire le djihad est bien quand il
revient je préfère qu'ils reviennent pas
mais bon si jamais il arrive à revenir
qu'ils soient surveillés qui soit que
l'arsenal le juridique soit judiciaire
soit considérablement renforcée voyez et
puis ça pose le problème de notre
diplomatie
parce que en quelque sorte on lance le
signal quand on nous explique les
gentils rebelles en syrie il faut les
soutenir qu'il faudrait presque les
armées et intervenir militairement pour
les aider on parle pas des mots
le socialiste on parle de 6 alors on
passe de l'autre opposition
les rebelles dont qui on parle de 5 %
des rebelles ceux qui ne sont pas
islamistes français que l'immense
majorité des rebelles entre guillemets
en syrie sont islamistes djihadistes et
notre diplomatie
les a soutenu publiquement alors des
esprits faibles zone malléable peuvent
tomber dans le panneau valence vous
dites il faut repérer notamment par
exemple les conversions rapide des
jeunes français est donné c'est l'appel
qui a été lancé par dalil boubakeur aux
imams et vous pensez que les imams
peuvent faire ce travail de repérage
également dans les mosquées et les imams
sont pas les fonctions de l'état
on peut on peut pas faire confiance à
tous les imams et un film à moi j'étais
pas confiants qu'ils veulent et ils le
disent contre la mairie mais il faut
aussi surveiller les prêches voyez et
puis ce phénomène là je pense qu'au bout
d'un moment il faut avoir l'honnêteté de
dire aussi qu'il est lié à une
immigration massive en large partie il
ya une immigration massive alors par les
jeunes convertis
oui il ya déjà converties avec hélène
converti puis même les jeunes convertis
vallée à se convertissent pas comme ça
par hasard c'est qu'un climat c'est
qu'il ya des quartiers entiers qui
échappent quasiment la loi de la
république ou non parce qu'on a accepté
la communautarisation on a accepté que
les règles d'un islamisme radical
s'impose aux lois de la république dans
certains quartiers et bien évidemment à
partir de là les esprits les encore une
fois les plus malléables les plus
influençables notamment chez les jeunes
peuvent tomber dans ce genre de dérive
gravissime on sait que ce type
d'entraînement et là ce n'est pas
réservé à la france puisqu'il ya des
centaines de jeunes européens qui sont
partis et qui partent l'écoutant de
partir pour la télé l'immigration
massive n'est pas réservé à la france
est ce que vous y allez prend une part
considérable puisque vous arrive vous
imaginez ne pas arriver en tête le 25
mai et avec quelles conséquences
politiques selon vos sujets possibles
ont acheté en tête on a lancé en tout
cas un objectif audacieux c'est d'être
premier parti de france est d'arriver en
tête je crois à créer une émulation
intéressante
maintenant nous ferons de toute façon un
très bon score voilà je rappelle que
notre record historique
concernant le front national pour les
européennes date de 1989
c'était il ya 25 ans et c'était 1 0 7%
la dernière fois nous avons fait nous
avions fait six la gueule 3 c'était en
là les sondages nous met je ne sais pas
à 22 23 24
combien mais peut-être lui c'était
devant l'ump on a vu manuel valls
s'engager fortement il ce qui te prend
un risque inconsidéré selon vous mais je
crois que manuela s'était engagée
fortement déjà aux municipales pour le
parti socialiste
bon on a vu le résultat n'était pas
encore premier ministre alors je demande
à manuel valls de s'engager encore plus
considérablement encore plus massivement
et le désastre électoral pour le ps sera
encore plus considérable et encore plus
massif c'est une sorte de machine à
perdre j'ai le sentiment manuel valls
alors est donc la nouvelle poussée du
front national avait tardé puisque j'ai
vu que sa popularité était déjà en début
de suite libre vos espoirs s'appuie
notamment sur les sondages effectivement
qui semble indiquer une nouvelle poussée
du front national pour l'élection
européenne pourtant il est un sondage
bva le parisien et qui indique que plus
de sept français sur dix ont une
mauvaise opinion de marine le pen
alors comment est ce que vous expliquer
ce paradoxe puisque une majorité assez
forte à la juge agressives démagogiques
raciste une minorité moins d'un tiers
seulement visionnaire et sympathique
n'est pas plus de 7 sur 10 mais c'était
un peu moins de 7 sur 10 - peu importe
écoutez c'est un sondage qui mesurent
déjà le bruit médiatique quand
effectivement dans l'ensemble des
émissions quasiment on dit que marine le
pen est tous les collectifs qualificatif
que vous avez employé quand ses
adversaires politiques tous se coalisent
en permanence contre elle et contre nous
on est leur obsession aujourd'hui la
plume une intervention du même du
président de la république ou du premier
ministre où on ne parle pas de marine le
pen ou du front national ce qui est tout
de même extraordinaire vu la somme de
problème réel concret qui se posent au
pays et qui devrait être la priorité des
responsables politiques
je viens nous nous mêmes comme nous
sommes dans les débats moi quand j'ai en
face de moi 1 ps 1 ump un centriste
inverse un front de gauche peu importe
au bout d'un moment et très rapidement
il ya systématiquement une coalition les
téléspectateurs le voit alors forcément
on mesure le bruit médiatique mais ça
n'est pas très important je dire ce qui
compte ce sont encore une fois les
sondages d'intentions de vote qui sont
très bons c'est la dynamique qu'on
ressent sur le terrain c'est la
dynamique des idées voyez on a des
expériences sociales
il ya de la désespérance sociale et il
faut il faut recréer de l'espérance en
france vous avez recréer de l'espérance
en france ça suppose d'avoir un projet
concret de redressement national je
crois que nous sommes les seuls à créer
cette espérance et même les seuls à être
capable de remettre des abstentionnistes
aux urnes et ça c'est aussi pour nous un
motif de satisfaction
mais il faut continuer
je vous parle de sondages
l'eurobaromètre qui est sorti
aujourd'hui c'est la sofres qui fait un
son agent tous les pays de l'union
européenne nous explique que
l'euroscepticisme montrent encore que le
sentiment national monte dans la plupart
des pays
on le voit en france par exemple en
france il ya plus que s'il ya plus que
28% des français qui font confiance à
l'union européenne contre 63% de choisir
des boucs émissaires c'est pas un bouc
émissaire la mission ne recèlent les
immigrés la voix parlée n'ont fait ces
migrants
personne n'a jamais parlé des immigrés
comme un bouc émissaire les immigrés
sont responsables de rien d'ailleurs
immigrés je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
parce que dans les immigrés vous avez
des français vous avez des étrangers
dont je n'aime pas ce terme
l'immigration l'immigration comme la
soumission à l'union européenne
les seuls responsables ce sont les
gouvernements français par exemple quand
ils ont bafoué le vote des français sur
la constitution européenne en 2005
gauche et droite confondues quant au
parlement ils ont fait annuler le vote
des français ils ont fait voter le
traité de lisbonne
là ils ont pris une part de
responsabilité easter en bas fois on est
parfois les pensées d'un des combats du
moment 1 c'est le fameux traité que
négocient l'europe avec les états unis
pour un traité de libre échange et c'est
un combat que vous partagez avec jean
luc mélenchon qui était à votre place il
y a quinze jours avec nous et le front
national selon vous doit-il voter la
proposition de résolution du front de
gauche donc à l'assemblée le 22 mai pour
exiger l'arrêt immédiat des négociations
oui il la votera donc mais bien sûr mais
vous savez nous on est un luxe son
secteur eux ils sont sectaires si on
proposait quelque chose qui va dans leur
sens il ne le voterai pas par principe
quitte à faire du mal au pays voyez et
aux travailleurs français
si nous nous estimons quelqu'un propose
quelque chose qui va dans le bon sens
même s'il n'est pas du tout de notre
bord politique on le vote
voilà en l'occurrence on le vote non moi
je préfère qu'on soit plus nombreux à
combattre ce traité pour espérer le
faire capoter notamment au parlement
européen que moins nombreux
comme je me réjouis sait par exemple
qu'en 2005 encore une fois sur la
constitution européenne
mais bien dans le nom il y avait toutes
sortes de famille politique mais au
moins ça a permis aux non d'être
majoritaire donc vous savez comme ça là
que de ça le ps et l'ump eux aussi
partage un combat mais partagent le
combat pour se traiter troubles ont
récusé bien sûr l'expression est un
drame d'extrême droite ce que vous
un jour les jusqu'à récuse l'expression
de droite nationale bien sûr mais le
principal n'est pas de droite il n'est
pas de gauche
il est aussi éloignée de l'extrême
droite que de l'extrême gauche il est
patriote et vous savez le clivage gauche
droite je pense qu'il est dépassé en
était depuis très longtemps
voilà moi je fais partie d'une
génération qui a grandi dans des dents
d'autres enjeux il s'était fini le mur
de berlin s'était finie la guerre froide
quasiment c'était sur la fin c'était
fini le bloc de l'est et et le monde
libre et ses astra mais je veux dire moi
j'ai grandi dans un monde qu'ils étaient
confrontés aux enjeux de la
mondialisation et là il n'y a pas de
gauche a pas de droite aux enjeux de
l'union européenne et on voit bien qu'à
pas de gauche mais pas de droite aux
enjeux de la question de la nation la
question la souveraineté la question des
frontières économiques financières
migratoires il n'y a pas de gauche n'a
pas de droite sur toutes ces questions
là voilà la question qui redonnera au
peuple souverain au peuple français
sa capacité de maîtriser son destin et
sa monnaie et où sa monnaie mais ça fait
partie du destin pour les salaires bas
de gauche à droite il ya les démocrates
et à ceux qui sont pas démocrates nous
nous sommes démocrates
comment expliquez vous que malgré sa
valeur peut être certes trop élevé
l'euro permet à l'union d'être
excédentaire au jour aujourd'hui dans
ces échanges un est par exemple
l'allemagne avec un excédent commercial
toujours par exemple à la souris avec
vous dans mary et je connais l'argument
l'excédent 200 milliards en allemagne
si bien que c'est pas là le gros la
cause s'est peut-être mis nos faiblesses
nous va en france nous sommes et nous
sommes déficitaires
donc là l'union européenne globalement
la zone euro globalement est
excédentaire parce que la veille avec
d'excellents terre mais parce que
l'allemagne bat et que d'autres pays
fassent et les rares à être déficit en
mai l'allemagne c'est le gros morceau de
l'excédent de la zone euro pour une
raison simple c'est que l'euro est bâtie
pour l'allemagne je le rose c'est le
deutschmark 2.0 les noms l'euro est
bâtie pour l'allemagne est d'ailleurs
madame merkel a dit il ya quelques jours
où il ya une semaine l'euro fort protège
la vigueur des exportations allemandes
mais mme merkel elle parle pas des
exportations européennes elle s'en moque
elle parle des exportations allemandes
elle a bien raison à défendre les
intérêts de son pays
moi ce que je reproche à nos dirigeants
c'est de ne pas défendre les intérêts de
la france l'euro n'est pas adapté à la
france alors il ya trois mois on nous
expliquait que l'euro n'était même pas
trop fort c'est notre
qui ne sont pas adaptés non mais au
moins on a progressé à éviter exigé
aujourd'hui le poème de coexister
aujourd'hui c'est notamment la question
de l'eau il ya pas que ça met la
question et vous allez on a progressé il
ya trois mois quand on disait que l'euro
était trop fort on se faisait insulter
aujourd'hui au moins ils admettent tout
ce que laurent et arrêter de dire que
vous faites toujours insulté à monsieur
cissé quand on est moyen je ne sais quoi
c'est insultant on va parler plus avant
d'autres grands enjeux de ce scrutin du
25 mai florian philippot avec la poussée
du vote contestataire qui devrait
constater également partout en france
avec des conséquences bien sûr pour
votre mouvement l'ambition de sa
présidente mais avec peut-être un
renforcement du coût des alliances au
centre pour permettre la poursuite de la
construction européenne que vous
dénoncez le sujet de jérôme bonnard
avant et guillaume daudin notre confrère
de la fp vendredi dernier à béziers la
présidente du front national boosté par
des sondages favorables affiché ses
ambitions
partir à l'assaut du parlement européen
et créer un groupe avec d'autres partis
d'extrême droite pour certains
adversaires ce n'est pas crédible non
ils pourraient venir à 100 110 120 ils
bloquent en rien du tout ils feront un
grand cinéma au parlement européen quand
ils sont là parce que je ne dois quand
même dire jusqu'à présent il faut bien
dire qu'à part deux ou trois jours de
session plénière on ne les voit pas
beaucoup et j'ai même remarqué des
endroits où on voit le front national
voté avec le front de gauche
en fait 25 eurodéputés issus de sept
états membres suffisent pour constituer
un groupe politique
cela permettrait d'obtenir plus de
subventions mais d'ici à peser au
parlement
cela reste à prouver le véritable
problème c'est combien de temps ce
groupe
durera sachant que nous avons affaire à
des mouvements qui traditionnellement
ont des agendas nationaux qui ne sont
pas nécessairement compatibles
car même si marine le pen peut compter
sur quelques alliés comme le populiste
et islamophobe néerlandais geers
builders ou encore le fp autrichien
d'autres partis comme le britannique et
europhobe ukip refusent de s'associer à
un mouvement qu'il juge trop extrémiste
au final face au bloc solide des 751
eurodéputés l'ondé de choc des extrêmes
n'aura peut-être pas lieu
ce qui serait ennuyeux c'est s'il n'y
avait plus entre les sociaux démocrates
les centristes et les sociaux-libéraux d
une majorité suffisante pour faire
avancer l'europe qui a toujours marché à
coups de compromis entre une gauche
modérée et une droite modérée mais après
le 25 mai prochain il faudra
certainement laissé quelques sièges
supplémentaires aux homophobes et autres
eurosceptique qui dans de nombreux pays
caracole en tête des sondages et où il
pourrait arriver en tête ou en seconde
place ferrer le front national pour l'
agence france-presse
c'est une rude mission vos questions à
monsieur finiront pas tant que ça
bonsoir florian philippot on a vu dans
le sud est qui les quelques alliés
européens dont on a parlé donc l e le ft
autrichien flammes ce bel angle la ligue
du nord aussi le parti de la liberté de
geert builders
il ya d'autres personnes avec qui vous
êtes en discussion les démocrates de
suède le parti national slovaque
ma première question c'est de savoir ce
sera une alliance politique ou une
alliance technique que vous comptez
faire au parlement européen ce sera une
alliance politique sur l'europe sur leur
faim surtout on n'est pas d'accord sur
tout mais ça n'a aucune importance
d'ailleurs puisque même chaque partie à
son histoire son contexte national et on
n'a pas pu a bâti le programme commun
loin de là n'ont en revanche on est
d'accord sur la question de la
souveraineté nationale par rapport à
l'union européenne
le fait de retrouver notre liberté par
rapport à ce machin bruxellois qui est
en échec total et qui en plus est
profondément dans son essence oligarchie
je n'ai pas démocratique c'est ça le
problème alors ça nous permettra d'avoir
un groupe qu'il faut sept nationalités
et 25 députés y travaillons et nous
sommes optimistes de sang du coup vous
allez peut-être vous alliez par exemple
avec donc le parti de la liberté de
geert linders garde wenders il est connu
pour ses déclarations chocs qui créent
des qui critiqueraient comment dire des
problèmes contre lui parce que par
exemple il a déclaré récemment il ya
trop de marocains aux pays bas on va
s'en charger il a été largement
critiquées aux pays-bas pour ça ou alors
il a comparés dans le passé le coran à
mein kampf pour vous c'est un céréalier
qui ça reste un allié possible c'est
génial on n'est pas responsable de tout
ce qui dit voilà il s'en explique je
crois que j'en ai expliqué
j'ai encore une fois je ne me sens
aucune responsabilité dans ce que dit
garde builders ou quelqu'un d'autre ça
l'âge comme j'imagine qu'au ps on doit
pas regarder l'intégralité des
déclarations de l'ensemble des membres
des partis alliés au ps dans le cas du
gse je suis pas sûr que vous alliez pas
si vous avez reçu par le chef du psc en
ce moment c'est le pc chef du ps bulgare
et ils sont alliés à ataka qu'un
mouvement d'extrême droite en bulgarie
voyez donc vous aurez à ce petit jeu là
on peut aller très très loin mais ça n'a
pas beaucoup de sens est ce que vous
auriez accepté au sein du front national
quelqu'un qui compare le grand - mais
n'est pas au sein du cru mais nous
allier avec lui c'est quand même en soi
déjà et c'est pas une alliance du tout
programmatique
c'est une alliance pour faire un groupe
sur un point précis qu'est la question
de la souveraineté par rapport à l'union
européenne
mais encore une fois on a bien compris
le petit jeu mais je veux dire faisons
ce jeu je pense sans aucun intérêt pour
l'ensemble des partis alliés à l'ump
dans le cadre du ppe ou alliée au ps
dans le cas du ps et on peut trouver
exactement la même chose c'est facile de
faire ça c'est un fait mais ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'intérêt
moi je suis pas garde builders et je
suis pas du tout je suis pas néerlandais
je suis pas de son parti
donc je me sens aucune responsabilité
dans ce qu'il dit ce que je vois c'est
qu'il entraîne dans son pays aucune zone
brûlée sur victoriaville et surtout en
tête dans son pays donc ce que les
néerlandais doivent être monstrueusement
épouvanté par par monsieur wenger
ils doivent adhérer à des idées qu'il
défend j'imagine il ya aussi l'ancien
ans il serait pas en tête après 30 % des
brillances vous savez aussi il ya quand
même une poussée de la xénophobie
partout mais aussi des candidats
lecture lisant existe s'il n'ya pas sur
les politiques ne fait pas la morale en
perdre non il ya un débat sur
l'immigration si vous parlez de cela par
exemple il n'ya pas de monter la
xénophobie
il ya un ras-le-bol vis-à-vis d'une
migration massive qui crée des problèmes
économiques sociaux et en termes
d'identité
voilà j'ai lancé un prince qu'il faut
traiter politiquement je veux pas
stigmatiser les gens en disant vous êtes
raciste ou je ne sais quoi
comme il faut traiter la question de
l'union européenne sans dire qu'il ya
des boucs émissaires c'est pas parce
qu'on considère que l'union européenne
l'a trahie l'ensemble de ses promesses
lequel ne marche pas du point de vue
économique social industriel et/ou mêmes
limites d'une pendule de l'immigration
et schengen qu'on stigmatise l'union
européenne ou qu'on en fait un bouc
émissaire
on a droit de débattre c'est pas une
entité métaphysique l'union européenne
c'est un objet politique qui a défini
des choix et des priorités par des
traités des directives et des règlements
eh bien on les discuter nous on
considère que ça ne va pas du tout que
on est la zone qui fait le moins de
croissance dans le monde et qu'il faut
réformer tout ça très très très profonde
et vous critiquez souvent le ps et l'ump
sur les affaires qui les touche parmi
vos probable alliés il ya aussi l'ancien
président lituanien hollande aspac sas
qui a été destitué pour des faits de
corruption dans son pays ça vous paraît
aussi je ne sais pas je n'ai aucune idée
alors là je sais même pas qu avec de
cuillé de quoi vous parlez
allez je vais pas me tuer ni envoyé moi
la différence saute avec les autres
c'est je considère que les français ça
existentielle aurait peut-être dans un
même goût et bleu mais je serai
représentants français au parlement
européen je serai pas le tua niant voilà
donc ils s'arrangent avec ses affaires
ça n'a strictement aucune importance
pour moi tant qu'accord bonvalot très
bien vous du coup vous dans ce succès
sont les consciences des affaires
pareilles jaillir des alliés de d'autres
pays du ps et l'ump qui ont que ceux qui
sont confrontés à des affaires il y en a
des tonnes n'aurait donc je pense pas
que vous demandez à monsieur copé ou à
monsieur cambadélis au vab semaine
sa responsabilité en matière d'affaires
en autriche en allemagne royaume-uni où
je ne sais où les analysant ce que les
autres partis enfin coalition européenne
présentent des candidats pour la
commission européenne qui est monsieur
schmitt pour les socialistes monsieur
juncker pour les conservateurs pourquoi
le front national n'a pas voulu
présenter de candidats avec ses futurs
partenaires pour la commission parce
qu'il ils dénient toute légitimité à la
commission européenne
d'accord mais vous vous donniez il me
semble la légitimité de l'union
européenne pourtant voulu présenter des
candidats non nous allons nous avons la
possibilité de peser au parlement
européen bien sûr parce que là il ya des
textes qui sont discutés parce qu'il ya
la possibilité de faire entendre la voix
de la france parce que nous serons les
trois blancs les seuls avocats de la
france et du peuple français parmi la
délégation française dont parmi les 74
députés et que les autres surtout les
messieurs cavada le qui disait à quoi
ils serviront les députés patriotes du
front national jira quoi il sert lui il
est dans un groupe de combien 200-300 il
appuie sur le bouton pour voter toutes
les directives que ses maîtres
bruxellois lui fournit alors juste et et
lui demande d'avaler bas il sert à quoi
monsieur cammas vous allez pouvoir faire
nous on sera là au député et bien par
exemple on pourra se battre sur les
élargissements à venir de l'union
européenne
mais pour interpréter physique quantique
vous aurez le choix pour nos feront tout
pour
et quitte à avoir des majorités de
circonstance bien évidemment mais
l'intérêt général prime sur le reste
il faut absolument qu'on se bat contre
les élargissements à venir balkans
turquie sur le traité transatlantique
est dramatique pour l'agriculture pour
l'industrie pour nos normes sanitaires
alimentaires etc
il faut qu'on soit sur des sujets
extrêmement concret contre l'austérité
aussi qui parle non pour moi c'est pas
une fatalité l'austérité il ya d'autres
possibilités il faut relancer la
croissance par un autre modèle
économique ce moment mais la commission
européenne joue à leurs résultats
aujourd'hui même le ps dire non à
l'austérité c'est leur slogan de
campagne
en fait il faut comprendre non à
l'austérité en europe mais mais oui à
l'austérité en france et j'ai vu le
pacte d'austérité de monsieur valls que
répondez-vous à jean claude juncker qui
a déclaré qui vote populiste ou extrême
droite votent pour les paroles creuses
ce sont des voix perdues il parle ou
dans le cas du débat luxembourgeois oui
il parle dans une interview au monde là
que j'ai su qu'ils calment je suis pas
monsieur juncker n'a pas de leçon à
donner
voilà qu'il donne des leçons à ses amis
luxembourgeois je n'ai pas de leçon à
ressorts de monsieur young
ni le monsieur schulz qui n'ont rien à
faire dans les campagnes françaises qui
n'ont pas donner de leçon aux français
qu'ils feraient bien de s'intéresser à
la campagne en allemagne c'est très
intéressant au luxembourg monsieur faire
obstacle c'est un autre candidat en
belgique mais ils n'ont pas vu alors
j'étais un cocktail de mardi par exemple
oui oui mais ça vous choque
il vient je crois d'ailleurs à forbach
ça me choque oui oui bien sûr ça me
choque tout à fait grattage non il est
pas persona non grata mais que des des
responsables étrangers viennent donner
faire la leçon aux français en leur
expliquant qu'il faut voter pour tel ou
tel parti
je veux dire je trouve ça choquant ou
alors qu'ils se présentent sur des
listes en france mais je trouve ça
éminemment choquant et et je trouve ça
lamentable de la part du ps est pour
l'instant des centristes peut-être de
l'ump peut se faire représenter dans le
fameux débat du 22 mai le seul grand
débat en prime time sur france 2 puisque
le ps veut se faire représenter par
monsieur schulz la vie c'est parce que
marine le pen a refusé mais monsieur
bayrou et notre avec lui monsieur mais
on aurait peur était la preuve elle sera
là c'est pour l'instant c'est celui qui
ne vient pas que les capteurs les
centristes veulent se faire représenter
par monsieur faire obstacle je crois que
monsieur copé devrait sera représentée
par monsieur juncker très logiquement
mais ça prouve quoi ça prouve qu'ils
sont dans une logique je suivais
nationales européennes n'ont pas
l'europe et l'europe c'est les nations
il y avait les français les allemands et
les italiens et de l'europe à nos
visions même partagé je pense par 99%
des français et l'europe sont des
nations là ils sont dans une vision post
nationale supranationale voyage
vous dites que vous entendrez france et
moi ça me choque parce que ça prouve que
la technocratie européenne
supranationale pour ces gens là pour les
responsables du ps du centre et de l'ump
plus importante que le débat la
confrontation directe avec les français
sur dix ne sait quand même que les
partis qui veulent faire l'union
européenne avance ensemble
il avance en reculant on voit le
résultat en faisant reculer les acquis
sociaux faisant reculer l'emploi en
faisant reculer la sécurité en faisant
avancer oui l'immigration clandestine +
48 % l'an dernier vers l'union
européenne sont ici de frontex
bref c'est un échec total cette machine
qu'on le reconnaisse pourquoi c'est un
homme considère que l'union européenne
est un objet religieux
avec ces dom son credo la caisse est
grand après addition très concrètement
si philippe g votre programme d'en face
celui de marine le pen mais c'est un
document commun vous dites c'est un
tract commun voilà ne vous dit que les
députés front national feront en sorte
d'organiser un référendum en vue de
sortir de l'union européenne
voilà c'est l'une des propositions je
vais juste comprendre comment un député
européen pouvait organiser un référendum
en france pour sortir l'union européenne
qu'elle est le plus nous serons puissant
et nombreux au parlement européen plus
nous enverront un signal national fort
parce qu'il ya évidemment aussi une
dimension nationale dans le résultat de
l'élection si françois hollande le 25
mai au soir et le 26 mai au matin se
réveille avec un front national premier
parti de france
près d'une vingtaine de députés français
front national rassemblement bleu marine
au parlement européen il ne pourra pas
se dire qu'il ya pas un problème avec
l'europe en france et de l'as organiser
un référendum de sortie d'un droit
qu'est ce que ça nom de l'union
européenne de sortie bien ce que ça
d'extraordinaire d'organiser des
référendums et je sais qu'en france on
n'aime plus les réformes menées en
suisse ils en font 3,4 par an en
localisant font deux parents et les
groupes ou bien ils veulent faire un
référendum sur la sortie du double fait
de constituer un groupe vous pensez que
ça va vraiment changer les choses que
vous aurez vraiment des pouvoirs
d'action sur l'union européenne
nous aurons des prérogatives
supplémentaires bien sûr et nous aurons
d une capacité de nous faire entendre
plus importante bien sûr que sinon le ps
et l'ump ne chercherait pas à eux aussi
à faire un groupe et ne seraient pas
déjà dans un groupe sûr mais on voit un
groupe ça permet d'exister alors ça
permet toustou ne changera pas avec le
parlement européen mais la mort mais
être plus nombreux plus visible avoir
plus de prérogatives est toujours plus
intéressant qu être moins nombreux moins
visibles avoir moins de prérogatives et
je crois que les électeurs français
doivent le comprendre c'est pour ça
qu'il est très très très important
d'aller voter le 25 mai
si on ne va pas on fait un cadeau à ceux
qui veulent l'europe de la continuité
vous parlez d'une opposition
constructive ça doit vous êtes prêt
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure à
voter des mesures qui seraient proposés
par exemple par des élus de gauche comme
le sont déjà nos députés
parce que par exemple récemment il ya
une motion au conseil régional de
picardie contre le traité transat l'iran
transatlantique que vous dénoncez une
motion cosignée par les vert et noir le
ps et vos élus se sont opposées à celles
ci oui mais parce que là si vous voulez
c'est pas un conseil régional qui décide
de sa autant au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale ou du parlement européen on
comprend bien vous l'avez dit vous
voterez avec jour le conseil régional on
est là dans le fuselage le plus total
des électeurs on l'est on essaie de leur
faire croire que la picardie va échapper
au traité transatlantique que tout ça
n'est pas très sérieux puis en plus si
ça vient des verts en partie c'est très
hypocrite parce que les verts c'est un
mouvement européiste s'affairaient quand
ça vient du front de gauche non
excusez-moi les verts on va au moins le
front gauche ils ont voté non en 2005 je
crois bon mélenchon il semble qu'il
était sur les tribunes du du nom autant
les verts sont un parti ultra européiste
qui adore l'union européenne donc ils ne
se plaignent pas des conséquences de ce
qu'il a lui-même créée voilà oui non
mais l'autre problème de mélenchon sait
qu'il n'est pas clair sur les sujets
européens
je viens sur la souveraineté nationale
comme il a un problème de fond avec la
nation ils n'en parlent pas sur les
frontières comme il ya un problème de
fond avec les frontières ils n'en
parlent pas donc il parle pas du
protectionnisme je ne sais même pas s'il
est protectionniste ou pas nous nous
sommes protectionnistes sur l'euro alors
là il est pour et contre
ça c'est le grand et ça change
apparemment ça change c'est en train de
changer
réponse nous et que nous nous
considérons que l'union que leurs hôtes
un échec et qu'il faut il faut en
revenir à 4 parce que ce qu'aujourd'hui
95% des pays du monde c'est à dire une
monnaie nationale espèces adaptées à
leurs économies pour nous ce serait un
franc dévalué
ben oui mais c'est bien d'avoir une
dévaluation à mes voeux les suisses ont
fait une dévaluation il ya deux ans les
britanniques aussi
résultat les britanniques l'an dernier
avait cinq fois plus de croissance que
l'allemagne une
balance du commerce extérieur
déficitaire sas et si tu piques pour le
royaume uni l'ont trahi finalement une
balance déficitaire mal aux états unis
en fait ce qu'ils ont ou japon ils ont
dévaluer leur monnaie et maintenant leur
balance commerciale
certes mais ils ont le royaume uni a eu
l'an dernier 2 % de croissance
l'allemagne 0-4 la france 0-3 je regarde
les chiens c'est bien franc dévalué
alors que la france ne réalise réalise
90% ses exportations au sein de la
nommer l'euro ce que je comprends c'est
vous dire demi heure l'euro est
peut-être trop fort oui c'est vrai bâle
un problème donc à évaluer c'est à dire
moins fort oui mais pas les autres
choses à dans les mêmes proportions que
le terme est paré est mal compris ça
veut dire moins fort moins fort par
rapport au dollar d'ailleurs parce que
je pense que le froid le franc serait un
petit peu plus fort que maintenant par
rapport à la lyre ou la peseta qui ont
besoin elles une dévaluation plus
conséquente par rapport au dollar comme
souvent que mais ce serait bon pour les
exportations bien sûr ce serait très bon
pour l'industrie française et pour
l'emploi et la monnaie c'est juste un
instrument s'est pas vu proposer % de
nos exportations hors zone euro n'ont
aucun autre richesse du tout même à
l'intérieur de la source à l'intérieur
de la zone euro est bien évidemment
avant que nous avions différentes
monnaies nous pouvions jouer de cela par
rapport par exemple à l'allemagne
aujourd'hui on est mieux au régime
allemand et le rouge au lycée le
deutschmark 2.0 alors forcément on est
plus compétitif même au sein de la zone
euro mais le coût des importations par
exemple pour être enchérit du coup ça
dépend de très marginalement parce que
la prime sur le prix de la sueur non
c'est faux le prix des produits
le prix des produits c'est marciana
inexistant c'est marginal assure le tri
j'ai pris des produits c'est marginal
dans le prix global d'un produit le prix
de la matière première et ensuite par
exemple venant d'italie ou d'espagne ce
serait l inverse concernant l'essence la
grande partie la majeure partie du prix
de l'essence ce sont des taxes ou les
tsars bien sûr bien sûr par contre on ne
dit jamais ce que ça créerait comme
avantage il faut lire jacques sapir qui
explique les points de croissance
supplémentaires que ça amènerait et
surtout nous arrêterions nous endetter
en permanence pour sauver tous les
quatre matins cette monnaie qui n'est
pas adapté encore une fois on va pas
s'endetter et payer ad vitam aeternam le
prix de l'austérité c'est à dire le prix
de l'euro merci guillaume merci merci
père y goûte arnaud arrive maintenant
mais juste avant cette enquête a été
menée par marie brémaud sur votre
ascension au près et même au plus près
de marine le pen
il n'est jamais bien loin de la patronne
sur les photos ou devant les caméras
derrière marine le pen il ya presque
tout le temps florian philippot et
pourtant le numéro 2 du front national
était il ya encore quatre ans inconnu du
grand public et des militants frontistes
ça qu'il n'est pas là depuis très
longtemps au sein du front national est
tout de suite elle a été bombardée un
poste très important donc vice-président
et s'occupe de la communication et gère
en partie le programme les inflexions
sur l'euro l'économie plutôt que sur
l'immigration en 2009
marine le pen rencontre le jeune énarque
chez le souverainiste paul marie
coûteaux
elle repère en lui l'architecte de la
dédiabolisation le visage de la façade
respectable du fn il a beaucoup
contribué je crois à modifier l'image
sinon marine le pen du moins celles du
front national à travers marine le pen
c'est un peu pour ça aussi qu'elle n'a
choisi non seulement ses compétences
propres mais aussi l'idée qu'il venait
d'ailleurs non seulement de lennar mais
peut-être deux une tradition qui avait
pas tout à fait sa place jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'heure au front national mais il
connaît les rouages de l'état et
participe à la professionnalisation du
front national petit à petit le fidèle
florian philippot prend goût à la
lumière omniprésent dans les médias mais
aussi auprès de marine le pen
je crois que tout fait pour se rendre
indispensable et le dispensable
un dévouement qui lui a permis de gravir
les échelons mais qui le place également
à la merci de la présidente du parti
durement qui la leur les bonnes grâces
de marine le pen fille les flancs
philippe on ne craint rien et forcément
franchi dépôt il incarne le renouveau
qu'elle soit apportée à son parti mais
une fois que marine le pen
on aura marre aussi un si un différend
entre eux il peut très bien connaître
une sortie de route assez rapide au sein
du parti beaucoup espèrent cette sortie
de route
l'ascension fulgurante et le profil
atypique du trentenaire parisien on
agace plus d'un
on la perd une paire ne nous ait rejoint
pour sa part une question pas marin
jours filent la distance à florian
philippot samedi paul marie coûteaux
danel un petit peu énigmatique comme toi
dans le reportage
c'est vrai que votre ascension
fulgurante au fn a parfois créé des
tensions des rivalités pour l'instant
vous n'avez jamais remporté d'élections
ça va être votre troisième essai cette
troisième tentative ces européennes
après les législatives et les
municipales en mars dernier à forbach
là ça devrait passer est ce que cette
élection européenne être élu député
européen c'est un moyen pour vous de ce
soir votre légitimité au front national
bon déjà les deux premières élections on
a fait à chaque fois le meilleur score
historique que le front avait jamais
fait dans le coin on n'a pas gagné c'est
vrai mais on a contribué à ancrer le
mouvement et on gagnera la prochaine
fois alors sur les européennes
non ce n'est pas l'objectif principal je
viens l'objectif c'est d'abord de
conduire le mieux possible cette liste
du grand est d'en faire passer le plus
possible mais on peut peut-être en faire
passer 3 je pense dans l'est et puis
bien de contribuer puisque je suis aussi
directeur national de la campagne des
européennes à la dynamique la plus
importante sachant qu encore une fois
les français nous ont rencontrés sur la
question européenne mais être élu pour
vous savez quand même être important au
sein du front national il ya un congrès
en novembre prochain
les militants vont voter pour élire leur
direction au sein du front national donc
ça vous donne quand même une légitimité
démocratique non c'est pas un plus au
sein du front national mais la
légitimité ni pratique elle est
importante tout simplement dans la vie
politique
quand on fait de la politique c'est pour
être élu pour exercer des
responsabilités et quel que soit le
niveau fut aussi conseiller municipal et
conseiller communautaire et pour faire
avancer ses idées sa maman aussi non
sinon d'alarmant on tourne en rond
l'objectif c'est évidemment d'être aimée
jugé c'était pour rebondir un peu sur le
sujet comme le disait le journaliste
venait
ailleurs entre guillemets c'est vrai que
vous aviez un petit peu un profil
atypique au sein du front national et
que votre ascension a été a été très
rapide donc après avoir été propulsé en
quelque sorte par marine le pen
maintenant on va peut-être falloir
conforter votre place de numéro deux non
mais je viens d'ailleurs ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que j'étais
effectivement pas au front national
avant de la rencontrer que je me définis
moi vous le savez comme gaulliste que je
crois que j'avais mounir nadine morano
qui distrait de nationalistes elle enfin
nadine morano il ya le problème quand on
est en campagne dès qu'elle sait qu'il
faut en permanence sied de relever le
niveau quoi parce que le tire vers le
bas c'est bon enfin nadine morano année
pagonis pas parce que nous n'avions plus
parce que nadine morano ce qui a laissé
police patriote et européen
ben oui mais si elle était gaulliste
déjà elle n'aurait pas comment c'est ça
sa campagne sur la tombe de robert
schuman premièrement et deuxièmement
elle ne serait pas en permanence en
train de nous expliquer que la
souveraineté nationale c'est dépassé
elle n'aurait pas voté tous les traités
européens et toutes les directives et
surtout la morale aux députés ump le 4
février 2008 à versailles n'auraient pas
voté le traité de lisbonne ce qu'elle a
fait comme député ump et donc à la voter
un texte qui avait été rejeté par
référendum
alors vous savez à quel point le général
tenait au resto résultats des
référendums
il a lui-même été victime les murs vous
êtes un gaulliste assez isolé au sein du
front national marine le pen à la
réunion elle se définit pas comme un
gaulliste mais peu importe je verse plus
que ce qui fait la force du front
national c'est nous sommes attachés à la
patrie à la nation voilà la france alors
certains diront rien qu'un gaulliste
atrium souverainiste est dans un parti
qui ne soit pas attaché à la france à la
nation bastille où ses émotions sont pas
les joueurs et les reins je vais pas me
dire que telle ou telle ne l'est pas
mais j'ai dit simplement que dans le
fond laissé entendre mme banon mais j'ai
dit dans leur politique là si je regarde
le fruit de ce qu'ils font et je jure un
arbre à ses fruits
il n'y a pas de défense de la france il
y à des attaques en permanence contre la
france voilà c'est tout ce sont des
partis ps et ump mais aussi les partis
satellites qui gravitent autour d'eux
qui sont leurs alliés front de gauche
verts centre etc des partis qui ont fait
beaucoup de mal à la france ont répondu
d'ailleurs que sortir de l'europe cette
affaire je sais que qui aime bien châtie
bien mais bien ça c'est bien je pense
que ça s'applique pas pour un pays
voilà ce qu'est ce qui vous différencie
aujourd'hui de marine le pen haskell des
sujets sur lesquels vous n'êtes pas
d'accord
un point alors sur le pas sur le point
du programme puisque le programme
prévoit un référendum sur la peine de
mort c'est un choix entre la perpétuité
réelle ce qui est mon option où la peine
de mort ce qui est son option et moi
voilà je ne suis pas pour la peine de
mort je suis pour la perpétuité réelle
on n'est pas à l'ump il ya beaucoup de
divergences aussi la balle un peu en ce
moment c'est terrible si vous voulez
auparavant avant à l'ump les les
souverainistes avaient encore le droit
d'en fumer il avait une autorisation
d'enfumer monsieur guaino était là pour
pour enfumer
maintenant ils n'ont même plus le droit
de parler alors on l'a on les sommes de
partir de quitter le parti
passée une formidable tarification qui
est en train de se produire à l'ump
voilà les déclarations de monsieur juppé
monsieur raffarin écopé à l'encontre de
monsieur guaino et bien sont une très
grande clarification parce qu'elle
démontre que l'ump a fait le choix très
clairement maintenant de l'union
européenne fédérale de la voix fédéral
et une voix qui est un souverainisme
qu'henri guaino à sa place au front
national ce que vous dites moi j'ai
toujours pensé un jeudi que s'il
écoutait son coeur il se réduirait plus
longtemps mais même chez seulement il a
d'autres ressorts et d'autres
motivations
en tout cas on lui a dit de quelqu'un
non mais d'autres lui ont dit qu'il
n'avait plus sa place à l'ump pour gérer
l'ump
donc je vous dit rien parce que je donne
il fait ce qu'il veut mais mais mais
derrière j'ai vraiment aimé autour de
nice et pas assez pas que guaino souley
il ya quand même encore probablement des
électeurs de l'ump qui se sentent
souverainiste patriotes gaullisme et qui
viennent de se prendre une raclée mais
phénoménal de la part de la direction de
l'ump qui le respect qu'ils n'ont plus
leur place dans ce parti ben c'est ce
que j'appelle une clarification parce
que ça faisait longtemps que dans les
faits dans sa politique l'ump avait
tourné le dos à ses idées nationales un
mot peut-être pour finir de la réforme
sur la décentralisation votre ligne au
front national c'est comme une puce
département ça c'est votre schéma vous
vous refusez les
les régions est ce que ça vous semble
bon levier économique commune plus
département pour la france commune
département est à nation les autres sont
sur intercommunalités région europe
voyez nous on est dans la tradition
républicaine alors le ce que nous
voulons c'est que les régions soient
limités à une sorte de coordination
entre les départements qu'il n'y ait
plus d'élus régionaux propre ça fera une
source d'économie la d'élections
nationales
non il ya encore des élections
régionales ce serait facile on laisse la
place aux autres
non mais à ce moment là les alors les
socialistes ne présenteront pas de
candidats aux élections cantonales parce
qu'ils ne croient pas aux départements
fin ce raisonnement n'a pas de sens non
les régions doivent être une instance de
coordination entre des élus
départementaux mais les mêmes comme ça
il ya plus d'élus propres de la même
manière les compétences stratégiques de
la région comme le transport régional
par exemple où la formation
professionnelle doivent revenir à l'état
puisque le stratégique c'est l'état
alors que les compétences de proximité
comme la gestion des lycées doivent
revenir au département et puis il faut
supprimer
autre source d'économies les conseils
économiques et sociaux régionaux qui
sont comme il faut supprimer d'ailleurs
le conseil économique et social écho
national parce que c'est une source de
gabegie énorme et que ça ne sert
strictement à rien ces conseils ne
servent à rien du tout si c'est un
recaser les copains je craignais comme
jean françois copé que le projet du
gouvernement accueille hal vers plus de
fédéralisme avec une génération dorée
dieu vers un démantèlement de la nation
mais je crois que l'ump ça n'est pas
contre mais on l'ump ne veut pas n'est
pas défavorable au projet des grands
länder des onze ou douze régions qui
sont à risque pour l'unité nationale et
qui en plus entraînerait des coûts
supplémentaires parce que ce serait des
grosses baronnies les grosses féodalité
et vous savez qu'à chaque fois qu'on a
fait ça on a créé des coûts
supplémentaires perrine vous avez été là
ont la folie des grandeurs sur tous vos
points communs avec marine le pen
morar divergentes est ce que vous
partagez la même admiration que la
présidente du front national pour
vladimir poutine non mais pas de
l'admiration moi je n'admire que les les
personnages historiques français non
mais on m'a déjà posé la question mais
marine le pen n'a pas dit ça comme ça
elle parlait d'un point très particulier
et je la rejoins sur la capacité qu'il a
eu effectivement de vous mettre sa
défendre international puis de remettre
son pays dans le concert des nations et
de redresser l'état face aux oligarchies
et s'est pas totalement terminée mais
voilà on peut pas dire que de ce point
de vue là et il n'est pas le vrai pour
son pays maintenant il n'ya pas
d'admiration comme ça on est dans la
realpolitik
c'est moi quelqu'un qui est un adepte de
la sortir de là de la guerre froide
c'est mieux n'a pas de raison d'être en
guerre avec la russie même la tente même
froide
il faut coopérer avec tout le monde ni
ne pas être sous zéro ni américaine
c'est mieux mais ça veut pas dire être
soudé gémonies russin certainement par
et la france a sa propre voie vous
estimez que l'union européenne doit se
tenir l'élection présidentielle qui va
se tenir en ukraine le 25 mai jeunes
estime que j'estime que la france
puisque l'union européenne juste mais
qu'est ce qu'elle peut dire il ya des
intérêts divergents
la france doit faire en sorte que cette
que l'ukraine préserve son unité
probablement par une fédéralisation du
pays et que on évite l'embrasement
voilà il faut vite trouver effectivement
les autorités légales et légitimes pour
ce pays merci merci merci merci plein
philippot merci à vous merci et à très
vite
bon